in the production notes colin says that
he he gave um you and emily just a whole
ton of credit for defining who kayla is
and you know how she changes over the
course of the story that we see unfold
on screen so i guess what were some of
the biggest differences between the
version of the character you saw on the
page day one and what we see in the
final version of the film
uh i gave kayla a dialogue pass
i gave kayla a full dialogue pass i mean
she was already very clear on the page
you know i i had a couple of touchstones
that were non-negotiable her backgrounds
her background she was always air force
you know i knew that there were certain
moments in the the script that um i had
to execute so i knew that she had to
have a certain physicality for you to
believe that she could pull chris pratt
out of the water because he is i don't
know how many times my actual size um so
were there certain things that i that i
wanted to ensure that were true but also
you know the kind of trust that he gave
me um
uh you know we workshopped her truly
like old school theater nerd we both
went to nyu workshopped her for a couple
of weeks to really refine and integrate
her backstory you know and that's a
process that um
i don't know any better because i come
from indie film so i'm just used to a
certain degree of collaboration but you
know it was a real gift and an act of
generosity and trust on colin's part um
to just let me kind of like do my thing
oh you said the key word there i'm a big
backstory nerd even when we don't
necessarily need it in a finished film i
love hearing about it you feel it
you definitely feel and i think you feel
it coming through kayla so you know
again we don't necessarily need this on
screen in dominion but did you ever just
for fun i guess come up with any other
missions regarding dinosaurs that kayla
had been on oh a trillion percent i mean
you know and i talked to them a lot of
them uh which i won't say because you
know maybe they'll be like another thing
i'm i'm vying for enough anyway that's
not the point point is um you know i
talked about it a lot funny enough one
of my um co-conspirators with kayla
which you can see very clearly in this
film uh was joanna johnston and in the
construction of that character so a lot
of her adventures we built into the
wardrobe
i love that
a lot of the toys and trinkets
are there any
details people can look out for there
was one where you know she had this
moment and it's probably going to be in
like in the extended cut maybe we'll see
but she has this beautiful pair of like
brass knuckles and we have this entire
like back story of this adventure um
that she'd gone on like in south africa
girl i love backstories uh where she
procured these you know these knuckles
because a lot of kayla has this kind of
you know indiana jones you know
she's just she's been everywhere some of
her travels are for work you know and
she goes on them because she has to go
on them and some are just for her i love
it so much now i want like a whole a
whole series like the adventures of
kayla when can we get that she's great
how about her take on the events of
jurassic park and jurassic world because
like she's alive and in the world as all
of this chaos is unfolding so how do you
think that those issues and instances
impacted who she's become and who we
meet at the beginning of this film that
is a great question and i can tell you
outright i think you know so much about
when we meet her
is just this level of
she really makes a true heroes like call
there's something that's awakening
inside of her when we meet her at the
top of this movie and it's because
she's in part very like
disillusioned
you know she's very like disillusioned
and disappointed at you know the the
folly of man you know and and she's in
this place when we first meet her that's
just like if you can't beat them join
them and she's just made a living of
the the mistakes of the people who have
come before her so you kind of have this
sense of just like this level of like
resignation but there's something that's
building in her that you're just like
that she's come to the end of her the
line of herself where she's just like
there is something i can do though
actually you know and that was really um
that was really inspiring to me to be
like we can all be heroes in a way you
know and that at any moment we can make
those turning points for ourselves to
stand up for something when we see
something happening i love how that
reflects the overall story and themes of
this franchise with mankind continually
making the same mistakes and hopefully
starting to realize you can actually
stop and change the course of events
here yes absolutely exactly oh my thank
you so much for your time today and i
can't wait to dig into like some i'm
going to bother you with very very
specific questions i i requested that so
please yes please brace yourself i can't
you